my friends i hope you are prepared for
the next story we have for you and i
hope you're prepared to sit i hope
you're sitting down for this
with the amount of people that are
estimated to be trapped in afghanistan
be it afghan allies even the citizens
but american citizens especially who we
have a responsibility to as our as our
you know
our brothers and sisters our comm you
know as well as our afghan allies for
sure
and to humanity in general
there's estimates between a thousand two
thousand the low end where they're like
oh there's about a thousand or two
thousand left of american citizens we
gotta evacuate some are saying that it
was you know nbc news report fifteen
thousand then they evacuated about four
and a half thousand so it might be ten
thousand
when we hear
and i want you to remember this that
there are american hostages i want you
to remember what the biden
administration did
from politico
us officials provided taliban with names
of americans and afghan allies to
evacuate quote basically they just put
all those afghans on a kill list said
one one official one defense official i
don't see why that would be
untrue for the americans biden did this
with vladimir putin remember that he was
like hey here's the list of things we
don't want you to attack and they're
like thanks for the hit list of your
most important infrastructure now
they're coming out and being like here
are the people we really care about like
oh so the ransom's double day or not
even the people we care about hey by the
way here are these people these people
have been hiding they've been begging
for help it was actually my my old buddy
from washington examiner uh phil wegman
who's now with real clear he was the one
who asked the president today at the
press conference about this report he
says can you comment on and the
president essentially confirmed it
saying there may be such lists being
given to the taliban but i'm not sure
which is again that doesn't inspire a
lot of confidence in me that the
commander-in-chief apparently doesn't
know what's going on over there we've
seen the taliban beating people there's
a video of an australian man he's being
beaten he's covered in blood the taliban
can claim whatever they want but they
look the the leadership like you
mentioned just previously in that they
want to be seen as they they do want to
be seen as a legitimate government
they're calling themselves the islamic
emirate of afghanistan they don't want
to be just this rogue element the
taliban they want to be the government
but they can't control their own people
right stuff gets leaked look that list
is going to get leaked look even if they
want to be a legitimate government i
think the fact that we're losing side of
the fact that it's the fanatic death
cult
and we are now completely at their mercy
we are look i i can i can get down this
road later we are the greatest country
the biggest superpower
i love america and we are completely
beholden to the whims of fnatic death
cult in afghanistan by choice by
choice and the fact that there's a
question about whether this
administration won't move earth in
heaven to save its its own
citizens any country or at government
that doesn't make every possible effort
to rescue its own people is not a
country that deserves to be won i gotta
read you this paragraph
u.s officials in kabul gave the taliban
a list of names of american citizens
green card holders and afghan allies to
grant entry into the militant controlled
outer perimeter of the city's airport a
choice that's prompted outrage behind
the scenes from lawmakers and military
officials it seems like the biden
administration is
treating these people like
any other country or government when
they literally just stormed in killed a
bunch of afghan security forces started
taking over cities and they're like
yeah here here's a list of names for
your checkpoints do you think that the
taliban checkpoints are legitimate
checkpoints where they're gonna be like
oh yes an american passport right this
way sir or they're gonna be like we got
an american okay right that way sir
maybe to your point they might for the
americans because they don't want to
start another another match who knows if
biden will actually make good on his
threat you know if that isis k will be
met with swift retribution those afghan
allies those people are as good as that
the taliban will make an example out of
them oh yeah they those people don't
have a chance now they know where they
are and they know they're coming this is
the one thing that i think might might
naively be giving me hope that the
taliban is scared you go you you start
you start going after these american
citizens and you're gonna get you're
gonna give them an excuse for re-entry
and they want the americans gone they
want us out right the afghans who are
staying behind
well they're the they're the apostates
they're they're refugees they should be
admitted status refugee status our
allies oh absolutely the translators the
families of the translators the fact
that we didn't get them out first what
were we what did they we knew this was
going to happen we knew the taliban
would come after these people anyone
with the target we saw this in iraq
after isis came out i got it my brother
served in iraq as a us marine and one of
the first things isis did when they came
to power and started marauding through
the middle east is they killed anyone
who worked with the united states
marines so a lot of guys my brother
worked with are now dead
there's precedent for this
but where we're at right now is that u.s
officials actually gave the names of
these people to the taliban that that
that's a kill list that i agree with the
defense official like we can say we're
crossing our fingers
that the taliban has enough control
they're going to say get these americans
out of here before we cause more trouble
but this list of afghan citizens who
worked with them
bad they're done i mean the
administration in this regard i think is
correct and is that we have shared
interest with the taliban we want to
leave they want us out so they may play
ball to a degree but the fact that here
we are hoping and praying please fanatic
death cult play ball i mean this we put
ourselves in this the biggest most
powerful country in the world aside from
maybe china is put itself in this
position and now we're just hoping and
praying but i'm telling you you know
those african allies they're as good as
dead you know how we put ourselves in
this position how trump was anti-elected
could you just explain that
there was no enthusiasm for joe biden in
the election none it was like 20 or
something enthusiasm for donald trump
was in the 90s enthusiasm against trump
was also very very high yeah and so this
is what happens
when you say
we will literally vote for anything
because the orange man is bad
we had a man
in joe biden who couldn't talk so they
made up that he had a stutter you go
watch videos from joe biden when he was
in the scene he doesn't have a stutter
he never
maybe was a little kid i guess fine now
they're claiming that his inability to
speak his his memory failings oh it's
just uh he's got a stutter stopped being
mean to him no no no
people were willing to elect a man who
was old and incapable simply because
they hated trump
and i i mentioned this the other day i i
genuinely believed there would at least
be adults in there i'm like okay well
you know this happened but there's some
there's going to be some adults in the
room who are at least going to be like
you know when grandpa falls asleep i'll
i'll take this over and we'll we'll
finish up these documents and get a plan
ready and just you know wheelchair him
into the sun with a little burlap
blanket on his lap
no they didn't and now now i kind of
understand what's really going on this
administration that biden's at the
meeting and he mutters and stumbles and
they all just kind of look at each other
and go whatever because all i care about
is me where's kamala harris when all
this goes down don't look at me she's
gone
so now i i genuinely believe that in
this administration with joe biden
millie
you know uh kamala harris
they don't know they don't care they're
probably just thinking like hey man i'm
not gonna do anything that puts me in
grants me the responsibility for this
one
so if biden mutters and falls asleep
we're just gonna say fine because then
when it all goes belly up his fault not
ours right instead of being adults in
the room and being like biden abandoning
an air force base for an embassy is a
bad idea mark milly what did he say he
said i was ordered to guard the embassy
did you maybe just think um mr president
we have to guard the air force base how
are we gonna how are we gonna evacuate
people no he was just like you got it
right white rage
right i mean these career bureaucrats
someone like kamala harris isn't going
to risk everything she's climbed her way
to the top to get in order to tell by to
know in order to save 20 000 people yeah
she's not gonna but is it really their
career are they really that craven i
mean to me this is one of those things
i'm trying to think of like a parallel
now it's too dark
it's pretty dark well okay catholic sex
abuse is such a clear-cut thing that the
church should be fighting i'm a roman
catholic by the way so i'm not just
dumping on the catholic church the fact
that it is struggling to deal with what
is clearly a vile and evil thing and
it's turned into like you know it's
difficult sometimes no no this is so
easy how are you struggling with this
likewise in a different thing that's
dark it's very dark let's get back to
the administration no but it's something
like that it was like how are you
struggling with the question of getting
every american out this is so easy this
is so basic every major great
civilization has put a premium on its
own people and the fact that they're
actually using language the one thing
watch this
jen sackey and all of them are saying
using that weird phrase that terminology
americans who wanted to leave right
they're already laying the groundwork
for the americans who are going to be
left behind because they can claim they
didn't want to leave actually the
president said that today in his press
conference he said there were a lot who
didn't want to leave because they got
family and the thing is once america
pulls out and taliban takes over who is
going to double check that claim a bunch
of american journalists are going to fly
into taliban controls afghanistan this
is priorities
what is the what what has the blind
administration prioritized nation
building
that's it
so when
when they decide they're going to be
getting out american citizens are not
their priority at all it's just this was
our priority we're leaving fine
everything else we don't give it we
don't get it how can not be no look
let's put the moral aspect the way that
it's morally decrepit that they are
dancing around this issue and hemming
and hawing on the issue of saving
americans and afghan allies let's look
at the political issue this is going
there's this doesn't go away i know uh
reuters reported reported recently that
the white house strategy is essentially
to just wait this out and they think
people will forget about it after it
comes and goes yeah no
this is going to be so much worse first
of all it already is worse than saigon
and saigon didn't have people with
cameras in their pockets everywhere you
had a couple of major news wires taking
photos everyone is going to see this and
i'm telling you if americans are left
and they're captured and they're made
into propaganda tools and killed and
executed you don't lit you you don't
weather that that no he's got he's got
to resign no he res and then you have
president commonwealth i know
i tweeted that i said with all the talk
about impeaching joe biden which would
you prefer president biden or president
harris
most people said president biden i know
right can i just take the arsenic
somebody said uh
don't don't forget to uh include pelosi
because if you get kamala i don't i
don't see grounds for impeaching kamala
well it turns into this whole weird
thing where the senator's already split
so i don't even think she gets the vice
president because that that's a lopsided
vote that's a whole weird thing on it
some that's a parliamentarian well we
get into the issue so
what is the political angle i can't look
the moral angle we can simply maybe
simplistically say they're just bad
people
which i think is fairly true at this
point but the political angle is like
what are you doing so i keep coming back
to this is why are we doing it this way
you are going to get killed in the
midterms you're going to get killed in
the election there are images of mass
groups of americans getting executed god
forbid i'm not going to knock on wood
like joe biden i god
he did that in his interview with george
stephanopoulos did you knock down wood
yeah no when uh stephanopoulos was like
is because was this the best way to do
it he's like look you know it's it's
working out and stephanopoulos said
there's a lot of pandemonium and the
president i'm not making the same stuff
but but look nobody died
and then he continued i was like oh god
you're actually knocking on wood
literally doing it you want to know so
politically you want to know why are
they doing this there's no upside to
what they're doing there's no rhyme or
reason unless chaos is the answer
because biden is
is incompetent he is well past his his
abilities to do this in his age and the
people around him are just sitting there
waiting to to scoop up the scraps
it's it's it's it's almost like there's
no one there to actually support
administration it's
that's why i say trump got anti-elected
because this is not an administration
they're not stepping up and saying buddy
let me take care of this let me try and
fix some of this they're just sitting
there i'd imagine kamala harris is
sitting behind the curtain with it with
a grin like oh it's almost my time this
is exactly what i was hoping for thanks
for checking out this clip from the tim
cast irl podcast if you want to see the
full show come back to this channel
youtube.com tim cast irl monday through
friday at 8pm where you can leave
comments and super chat and we actually
will read your comments on the show
don't forget to like share subscribe and
if you want exclusive members only
content segments you can't get anywhere
else go to timcast.com become a member
and we even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time